[Music]  hey guys this is gonna be super short  i just thought this was super weird i  just uh  i was just working all morning on  getting this like black widow movie  reaction up  on youtube which is now live by the way  but then i went on twitter  to you know share it and i saw cosmic  wonder put out this tweet here  and did marvel just accidentally  reveal a major spoiler  themselves like was this a mistake was  it supposed to be  silvie they meant to put in the photo  but until they put  b15 or did they just give away  that b15 is actually  a loki because you know you don't  actually  see her past when sylvie does the  enchantment on her  [Music]  which i thought was a great visual  moment but at the same like for  performance-wise but at the same time  now i'm like what is this spot on my  shirt at the same time i'm like  were there clues leading up to it was  this a mistake what do you guys think  i have no idea what to make of this this  is so this is so bizarre